-My first guest tonight is
one of the biggest movie stars
in the world.
-Whoo!
-Her new movie "Black Widow" --
Yeah, ow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Black Widow" is in theaters
and on Disney+
with Premiere Access July 9th.
Here is Scarlett Johansson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on, now!
-Hello.
-Ah!
It is good to see you.
-Hi!
-Hi, bud.
-How's it going?
-It's going great.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
I haven't seen you
since you got married.
Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thank you.
-I wanted to -- There's
many questions I want to ask,
but a couple questions if you
don't mind about you and Colin.
We love Colin Jost.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we know you're both
lifelong New Yorkers.
Do you ever argue
over pizza in New York,
where to get the best pizza?
-Oh, yeah, well, you know,
Colin is from Staten Island,
so that means something.
[ Laughter ]
You know, he really -- he's --
he's very specific
about his slice.
He'll definitely tell you the
best slice is in Staten Island.
-No, no, no.
-I respect that.
[ Laughter ]
I respectfully disagree.
I am from Manhattan,
and I -- you know, my --
Are you asking where
my favorite slice is from?
-Yeah.
-I got to say, by the slice,
I really love Joe's Pizza.
-That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, me too.
-I would say
for a whole pie though,
I got to go with Lombardi's.
I love Lombardi's.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
-Yeah.
-Yeah. It's all so good.
It just makes me miss going out
and getting pizza.
But Arturo's is somewhere
on that list too.
-Oh, yeah, Arturo's, yeah.
-Love that jam.
"Black Widow," finally.
"Black Widow" is here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's happening!
Are you excited
that it's finally out?
I mean, are you freaking out?
It's finally out.
-I am definitely excited.
I'm nervous about it, but it's
like a nervous excitement.
But I have been -- You know,
we've been sitting on this film
for over a year, and it's been
10 years in the making.
I'm super proud of it.
-Yeah.
-And people seem to really be
responding well to it,
which is fantastic.
-That's right.
-It really is a great movie
to see in the theater
because it's super cinematic,
explosive, loud,
fun, passionate.
-That's what we want! Let's go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, it's really great.
It's explosive.
-Is there any Easter eggs that
you can go like,
well, okay, maybe you can
give me one like,
are we finally going to get to
know what happened in Budapest?
-Yes, you finally get to know
what happens in "Budapesht."
-Mm!
-See what I did there?
-Yeah, you said "pesht."
That's right.
-I said "pesht."
-Yep, you said "pesht."
Have you been to Budapesht?
[ Laughter ]
-I have been to Budapesht.
-Yeah, see, I haven't. That's
why I pronounce it Budapest.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah, you finally learn how
to say Budapesht in this movie.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Yes, you get to find out
what happened in Budapest.
You really -- Yeah, you get
to -- I'm always so bad at this.
Let me see. What can I say?
I can say that, okay, you --
You know what?
You get to -- Ugh.
I can't!
[ Laughter ]
I can't say anything!
-You can't say anything!
[ Laughter ]
Because you can't say anything,
I'm trying to think, well, yeah,
you can't say anything.
No, I can't say is
he going to be in it.
-What can I tell you
about the movie?
Hmm?
[ Laughter ]
What? What happened?
-Well, just blink
if it's going to happen.
-Okay.
If what's going to happen?
[ Laughter ]
-Just blink if
it's going to happen.
-Are you --
[ Laughter ]
My eyes are still open.
-Yep.
So it's not going to happen.
Alright. Good.
We confirmed right here
on our show
that it is not going to happen.
-And now I have tears.
You made me cry.
[ Laughter ]
-You're getting
crazy-good reviews on this.
A lot of people are saying
it's almost like Marvel --
like a James Bond Marvel
because it's a spy movie as well
as a giant Marvel movie.
It is action beyond action.
There's motorcycles.
There's car chases.
There's everything you could
want in this thing,
and you got to be
really proud of this, bud.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Were you going to say something?
-Yeah. I'll tell you,
the clip, the clip.
Uh, I believe this clip
is part of a...
Oh, it's -- I don't even know
if I can say anything.
[ Laughter ]
-Then why did you interrupt?
I was going right to the clip.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a pursuit.
It's a pursuit.
We are in pursuit.
-That's not a scoop!
It's a pursuit?
Oh, give me a break.
-It happens in Budapest!
There, I said it!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There, you said it!
It's in Budapest! Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you!
That's all I wanted!
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Scarlett Johansson
in "Black Widow."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-Oh, I got you!
[ Grunting ]
No!
-Aah!
♪♪
-Ooh!
That's what I'm talking about!
[ Cheers and applause ]
See that in the movie theater!
Oh, my gosh!
And play it loud!
Scarlett Johansson, everybody!
"Black Widow" is in theaters
and on Disney+ with
Premiere Access July 9th.